and finally new role someone has to tell
me why all the best voices speaking out
against Republicans are Republicans
Nicole Wallace Steve Schmidt Rick Wilson
George will Bret Stevens Joe Scarborough
Richard painter Michael Steele Jennifer
Rubin David jolly and a Navarro max boot
David Frum they're the ones who are out
there with the gloves off landing head
punches even Trump's own people tear him
down better than any Democrat McMaster
called him a dope mad as a fifth grader
Steve Mike managed idiot Reince Priebus
idiot
John Kelly [ __ ] idiot Rex Tillerson
[ __ ] [ __ ] Gary Cohen dumbest [ __ ]
where are our potty mouths the midterms
are 52 days away and we know what the
Republicans are going to be running on
socialism you can't vote for Democrats
because they're socialists and socialism
is a work camp in Siberia and one thing
Republicans are really good at is they
get in a room together they come up with
a line of [ __ ] and they all repeat
it over and over and over until even
Tommy Loren can do it
this year they even taught it to trump
and they want to raid Medicare to pay
for socialism
he really puts them [ __ ] in oxymoron
remember remember back in 2009 the
teabagger at the town hall who shouted
keep your government hands off my
Medicare
well that dummy is now present but I
still don't hear Democrats explaining
that Medicare is socialism and so are
the other super popular programs like
Social Security and the ban on denying
coverage for pre-existing conditions
[Music]
Trump just gave farmers a twelve billion
dollar bailout to make up for his stupid
tariffs we took tax money from some
people mostly in New York and California
and gave it to [ __ ] farmers
I mean farmers that's socialism
socialism is the reason you don't have
to bring your own highway when you want
to drive someone
it's why there's a fire department to
show up when you're burning Nike spread
to the house
the US military does more socialism by
9:00 a.m. than Venezuela does all day we
build weapons that even the Pentagon
says it doesn't want that's a jobs
program socialism you're soaking in it
even Trump voters like their government
goodies so why can't Democrats all get
in a room and come out with a single
answer to these scary socialism charge
this is the attack on us and Democrats
response is I would say crickets but
crickets make some noise
there is a wholly compromised Russian
asset in the white house you can't make
a little political hay out of that he's
not on our side that's so hard he's not
on our side like literally when stuff
comes up where he has to side with
either our FBI and intelligence agencies
you know from America or what Russia
says he goes with them nothing nothing
to make out of that even though he's
constantly confessing it Trump's Twitter
pages like that scene in every Bond
movie where the villain tells Bond his
evil plan
he's the man with the golden shower
here's Steve Schmidt after the summit in
Helsinki
it's the musings of an imbecile Vladimir
Putin looks across to the other podium
and what he sees standing there is a
fool who's doing blat amir putin
spitting trump is what the russians call
a useful idiot someone in service to the
russian federation either unwitting or
wittingly
contrast that with Diane Feinstein who
said last year look this man is going to
be President most likely for the rest of
his term I just hope he has the ability
to learn and to change and if he does he
can be a good president no he can't do
any of those things and Democrats
rhetoric does not nearly match the level
of that crisis the Democrats as usual
are making a molehill out of a mountain
the FBI the CIA the Department of
Justice especially here on 9/11 week
let's remember these are the thousands
and thousands of America's most
dedicated public servants your straight
arrows
you to the straight arrows who protect
us he attacks them he's not on our side
how about this for a slogan
we're not socialists you're traitors